Mcfly : Ouais on est d'accord, la dernière coupe du monde elle était très bien,
mais 98 c'était fou !
Carlito: Frère, 98 c'était unique ! Mec, tu te souviens on a fait la teuf toute la nuit avec les darons, tu te souviens de ça ?
Mcfly : Grave, de ouf !
Squeezie : Bah moi je me souviens de rien parce que j'avais deux ans, voilà.
J'suis né en 96.
*Mcfly & Carlito : Choqués*
Carlito: 96, t'es sérieux ?
Squeezie: Oh ça va les mecs ça y est, allez, allez, allez
McFly: Attend par contre, t'as capté, nous on est nés pile 10 ans avant, en 86, gars !
Carlito: Attends, ça veut dire que t'as jamais connu les francs ?
Squeezie: Ça veut dire que t'es vieux et que moi je suis jeune, c'est tout ce que ça veut dire, gros.
Carlito: C'est méchant, c'est fou de dire ça !
Squeezie: C'est pas méchant, c'est la vérité.
McFly: T'as un peu le seum, c'est juste que les années 90, ça avait un autre charme.
Carlito: Et ouais, tu peux pas comprendre.
Squeezie : Ok... n'empêche que...
*GO !!!*
J'ai grandi dans les années 2000,
Pour moi tout était plus facile.
Issu du nouveau millénaire, il y avait tellement de choses à faire,
Vous, vous étiez en galère.
McFly : Ah ouais ?
On passait les repas de famille ensemble pas sur nos téléphone
On a connu l'arrivée de DBZ (Dragon ball Z)
et Olive et Tom
IAM et NTM étaient les rois du hip-hop
*remix : Les produits laitiers sont nos amis pour la vie*
Carlito : NAAANN !